gordon e sailor award is the only
academy award given out by
recommendation of the scientific and
technical awards committee to present
tonight's gordon e sawyer award please
welcome a sawyer award winner as well
mr doug trumbull
it's a great honor to be here this
evening
to be looking at peter anderson
uh i love peter dearly and i'm honored
to speak at this very profound occasion
of him being awarded the gordon e sawyer
award um
according to the academy rules this
award must go to an individual in the
motion picture industry whose
technological contributions have brought
credit to the industry and that is peter
anderson
uh peter peter was fresh out of art
center usc and ucla working in
advertising but somehow ended up at my
company future general corporation
working on steven spielberg's close
encounters of the third kind
uh working with me and my partner
richard uracich
and i don't know how he ended up there
and he's going to have to tell me
sometime
but he was
soldering together and gluing together
spaceships ufos and the mothership
and this was the beginning of a very
tremendous 40-year friendship that's
lasted to this very day
so whenever i need inside information or
on some
3d or some other obscure aspect of older
new technologies
i have to figure out who i'm going to
call
now i might have called richard edlund
because i'm deeply immersed in 3d right
now and he you know it's all about ghost
busting
from ghostbusters
but now when i want to know who to call
24 7 there's one person i can count on
and that's peter anderson thank you
peter
peter is peter is one of the most
gracious forthright and informed
creative gurus i know in the movie
industry
and i know now how much of a challenge
3d is
since i've only recently gotten into 3d
but peter has been there all along
pioneering this technology
developed modern 3d systems and
technologies for disney's theme parks
including captain eo and muppet vision
he also supervised imax 3d projects
projects such as cirque du soleil and
wild oceans
and he confidentially admitted to me
that during all this work uh that muppet
vision was not a rip-off of show scans
new magic
it was an homage
to peter
thank
you um
peter um
invited me a couple of years ago to
visit his uh
amazing 60 frame per second digital
gigantic screen 3d
attraction at universal studios theme
parks king kong
and that was when i finally knew that
peter was the go-to guy for the future
of cinema
because we both share a vision that
movies can be bigger
brighter higher frame rates more bit
depth more dynamic range and powerfully
experiential
and i have to tell you that peter is
the founding member of a secret society
that's subversively trying to change the
movie industry for the better
under peter's amazing leadership of the
academy's technology history committee
the council is developing a computerized
database
of academy scientific and technical
award applications going back to 40
1940.
this is a very important acknowledgement
that it's not just the people who win
awards but the people who try and toil
hard in obscurity
to help our industry and thank you peter
for acknowledging all these people and
making an archive of that information
peter has also begun
an oral history project where he puts
together a terrific crew of people many
of whom i know
and lures us into his inner sanctum to
record hours of exhaustively intimate
questions about the history of movies
he's interviewed uh people such as petro
vlajos
miyagisma ed de giulio richard glickman
don iwerks and even me
hours and hours of it
and we all tell our heartbreaking
stories of success and failure and he
records it for posterity
uh and his delightful mix of his great
sense of humor
and his incredible mental database of
the history of movie technology
allows him to ask the most probing and
horrible questions about everything
we've done
peter has a recently spearheaded
recently announced
academy of motion pictures
identification collection of important
historical technology related artifacts
such as cameras projectors sound and
visual effects devices gizmos and
certain films even that he thinks are
important milestones in history and i
think it's very important endeavor and i
thank you peter
for doing that hard work
peter is a member of the board of
directors of the visual effects society
he is active on the academy scitec
committee and the academy and ase's
technology councils he's a member of the
television academy at the visual effects
society the large format cinema
association cempty member and director
of photography and weird format frame
rate
strange everything
peter is the go-to guy and that it
commands my deepest personal respect
so it is my
immense honor
to be able to
present the gordon e sawyer award to my
very long time
buddy and friend and associate
hardworking pal
peter anderson
two years ago today
you had one of these in your hand with
your name on it
i'm so proud to be here
i'm so honored
this is the motion picture academy arts
of sorry
take two
this is the motion picture academy of
arts and sciences
arts and sciences you've heard it
tonight
sciences
that's what we're honoring here tonight
without the sciences what would the art
be without the art what would the
sciences be we are part of the blend
i look out here at all you beautiful
people all you wizards all you magicians
every one of you that has been honored
here tonight everyone that has been
honored in the past everyone that has
been will be honored in the future this
is how movies are this is how they exist
how this is how they will become
i salute you
for all of your
families your friends your wives
your companions
who have put up with us
i salute you even more
the board of governors has approved this
i find that very very precious
i honor you richard for chairing such a
great committee for so long
and i actually say that the great
meaning of this
is this
beautiful piece
this this
golden man
was given to me by my peers
on the scitec council
and
that is probably the most
valuable honor
is
just receiving this with the integrity
and the
good wishes of my fellow filmmakers i
thank you all
thank you it's been a long day
i am so appreciative
douglas
come here a second thank you
we actually sort of are like the biopsy
twins aren't we
we have a lot in common we do i do bless
you for coming here you too peter thank
you thank you so much for everything
to every one of you i salute
you have a piece of you in this
i am not alone it is you it is us that
as we as they thank you